et on reçoit et on reçoit notre premier
invité d'isabey de sedo bonsoir bonsoir
avant même de vous présenter une
question est ce que vous avez prévu
quelque chose ce soit pour la saint
valentin est engagée l'été style dessin
des amoureux car oui
l'enseignement est très très bien alors
ils avaient de fait dont vous êtes
passionné d'histoire de littérature vous
êtes diplômé d'un doctorat d'histoire
contemporaine votre secteur de
prédilection c'était spectateurs vous
connaissent c'est le parfum vous avez
une formation active c'est ça oui
et vous êtes d'abord complète on m'a
parlé des parfums avec vous mais d'abord
vous êtes en plein plateau pour parler
n'existe mans du dessert de la cin de la
saint valentin que vous avez mis en
place on peut appeler ça aussi une
émission racontez nous un peu l'histoire
de ce dessert en fait les serres de dr
exister ce soir les autres soit
exactement donc l'histoire et desserts
et enée enfin au moment où je
travaillais sur l' ouvrage dont que
j'écrivais l'histoire du parfumant de
marie antoinette
à l'époque les parfumeurs était aussi
des épiciers qui vendait des choses de
fin des mets de luxe comme le thé le
café le chocolat et comme à l'époque on
parfumait son chocolat on avait
différentes recettes pour le parfumer la
reine m'invente aurait par exemple aimé
besoin d'un lavandou à la violette et
puis les libertins eux ils avaient une
idée un peu différentes coupes les
libertins de la définition pour vous
d'un libertin l'époque alors antoine est
la même définition que l'on a
aujourd'hui julie b reprend alors le
libertin oui c'était d'abord un
mouvement philosophique avant d'être une
façon de vivre mais le libertin comme
son nom l indique c celui qui revendique
la liberté dans toutes ses dimensions et
notamment par rapport à l'art de vivre
donc il vivait il était extrêmement un
extrême raffinement si vous les dents
dans toute la sensorialité de la vie et
du coup évidemment
sexuellement aussi ils avaient des
libertés et le but était de ce plaisir
de jouir en fait ce plaisir de vivre et
plaisir aussi du coup avec un
décloisonnement des sens donc finalement
quand on boit ce chocolat on sait pas si
on boit un parfum aussi on mange un ou
enfin c'est on est on est complètement à
la lisière en fait entre les sens sans
boxer est à base de chocolat alors
c'était un chocolat très dense de cacao
en fait plutôt on dirait un haka qu elle
soit amer et qui va être parfumée comme
on le faisait à l'époque avec du musc
delambre gris et une triple vanille pour
adoucir le palais c'est quoi une triple
bonne et elle est une famille très
concentré c'est que les arômes
aphrodisiaques évidemment donc l'idée
était de leur être retravaillé avec la
modernité de notre époque et c'est pour
ça qu'on a on est parti sur une idée de
démission et pour redonner cette idée de
chocolat qui était plutôt un expresso à
l'époque vraiment cacao très dense et
puis également jeté avec un arôme à
titien qui a formulé cet arôme comme un
parfum avec vraiment où toutes ces notes
qui se décompose en bouche et qui donne
ce raffinement extrême que les libertés
avait à l'époque est permis et libertin
on avait quand même le roi louis 15 qui
aimait le déguster des malades voilà ce
rituel amoureux alors expliquez nous
donc ça c'est d'émulsion excuses et les
petits gâteaux les amarres et ti croc
ont plongé dans cette émulsion alors en
fait à l'époque a observé le libertin
c'est quand même celui qui rêve d'un
quelles libertés et notamment il y avait
un chef qui était pas très élégant pour
l'époque qui était de tremper donc
évidemment eu aimait tremper les choses
s'étaient plaints de suggestions et il
trempait un macaron à l'ancienne donc
c'est pas les macarons type la durée
c'est des macarons comme des amaretti en
effet ça quand c'est sec exactement que
catherine de médicis avait apporté va
apporter la recette en france leurs
moments de sa venue et donc qu'ils
trempaient un macaron parfumé au musc
dans leur chocolat alors comme là on
peut plus utiliser le musc comme à
l'époque du coup on a parfumé aux
bleuets
pour des questions d'éthique
essentiellement et donc c'est oui parce
qu'en fait le muscle c'est un peu
compliqué vous expliquer tout ça mais le
il faut tuer l'animal pour récupérer
voilà ces précieuses poche de musc donc
aujourd'hui c'est pas terrible donc on
le reconstitue avec la synthèse mais sur
le plan aromatique
c'est pas quelque chose qu'on utilise
aussi facilement donc du coup il fallait
trouver un substitut et on a décidé de
parfumer avec du bleu est le bleuet qui
était une fleur qui pousse est une fleur
champêtre qui pousse au petit trianon et
on sait que marie antoinette et mais
beaucoup se motive puisqu'elle l'avait
commandé pour son service deux sèvres
dit aux barbots donc on trouve voilà
c'est un petit clin d'oeil encore une
fois l'histoire donc c'est un dessert
aphrodisiaques alors oui
est-ce qu'on peut le trouver des cerces
pouvait travailler avec un on a vu
quelques images du dessin rejettera
louis un chef cuisinier de versailles
voilà lors de ce qui était amusant
c'était de le refaire on la refait à
quelques reprises on la refait notamment
avec à l'époque de gérard you trianon
palace et puis là c'était de refaire à
nouveau avec la modernité d'un à la
vision d'un chef d'aujourd'hui est donc
je me suis associé avec franc pommiés
qui est le chef de bia veneto à
versailles satory et donc ce soir voilà
ce soir vraiment d'excusés vitae et
uniquement pour un soir peut-être après
aussi on ne sait pas mais en tous les
cas ce soir vous pouvez le déguster chez
via veneto d'accord et donc il aura le
petit macaron voilà les macarons rouge
brésil azarenka on ose avec un petite
fleur de bleuets on pourra déguster sa
exactement ça d un dessert à partager à
parts à vue ben oui j'écoute savoir la
v7 macarons fond voilà on a présenté
cette macarons les macarons doit être
partagé à deux ans exactement après ces
taux
de natalité
ça va être en tous cas c'est assez chaud
on va continuer à parler avec vous
de la saint-valentin surtout des parfums
parce que des bons souvenirs vous de
saint valentin un peu étonnante
pas de souvenirs en partie facile quand
on porte le nom c'est parce qu'il y en a
pas mal il y en a pas mal moi je dirais
que la saint valentin ça peut être aussi
tous les jours donc ça vient d'ailleurs
qu'on sait tous les jours et c'est mieux
quand c'est tous les jours ça aux
messieurs c'est bien la saint valentin
tous les jours alors les fleurs faut pas
y penser seulement quelques instants
seulement faut pas attendre le 14
février pour se faire des petits
présents pour voilà il faut je trouve
qu'il faut entretenir la flamme alors en
tout cas pour entretenir la flamme il ya
une chef d'entreprise qui a une idée
plutôt originale nous thomas garreau
bonsoir voila bonsoir vous êtes un chef
d'entreprise spécialisé dans les
déclarations d'amour vraiment inédite et
on se dit qu en ce 14 février vous devez
surbooké 1
alors et dans les yvelines vous avez
deux scénarios particulier on peut
déclarer sa flamme bourdin bord d'un
avion avec un avion depuis l'aérodrome
de toussus le noble et puis aussi avec
des bougies ça c'est nouveau de cernay
alors parler d'abord de l'avion on peut
réserver un avion et puis met une super
banderole je t'aime
company men amoureux traîne pas dans
l'avion pour une jolie balade est en
plein vol laurent planton la cabine de
la réunion ne sont font qu'il est
important pour le couple est au même
moment il ya deuxième action qui surgit
près de l'avion des amoureux et sur les
ailes de l'avion il y a le message
d'amour qui est gravé et comme ça les
deux avions danse dans le ciel en
musique pour y accueillir c'est
magnifique c'est très joli qui fait
appel à vous plutôt les messieurs et
dames on se dit alors en fonction une
tradition mais 90% les personnes qui
font appel à mes services pour déclarer
leur flamme de manière spectaculaire
pour des sommes d'accord ça veut dire
que les femmes sont moins romantique où
c'est qu'on peut en avoir fait les
femmes attendent une belle déclaration
d'amour le mythe du prince charmant qui
se fait pas en forme en réalité le jour
de la victoire d'amour de la demande en
mariage donc c'est vrai qu'il ya
important pour les hommes de pouvoir
réussir le réclame ou et là vous avez
beaucoup de demandes alors cette date
particulière l'abbaye des maternelles
avec un joli scénario aussi qui permet
d'afficher alors qu'on arrive à l'abbaye
en pleine nuit des centaines de bougies
qui composent le message d'amour sont
vingtaine de mètres de large c'est
toujours très romantique et très
original alors on se doute que ça coûte
un peu cher non
alors ça commence à 90 euros pour ico
longue qui viendraient délivré un
message d'amour à l'être aimé ça peut
monter jusqu'à 4,9 en europe à gaza
ville des amoureux à la colombe aux
accoutrements
peut monter à 15 9 euros pour qu'ils
voient carrément déployer une patrouille
aérienne qui veut dans le ciel allait
mourir fumigènes bonjour c'est un appel
personnel moi ça me calme revienne
patrouille à l'ancienne alors là par
exemple sur sur l'avion depuis
l'aérodrome de toussus le noble il faut
compter combien par exemple alors qu'un
scénario
spectaculaire
fait pareil on déploie les grands moyens
il faut être quand même sacrément sale
impression ah oui mais j'ai croisé tu
t'es à leur insu une radio un homme un
peu stressé parce que il est en train de
bouquets ses places de théâtre il
fallait qu'ils réservent un bouquet de
fleurs envoyées et puis restaurant jeudi
mais dont autrement allez on a de la
chance allait me dit mais moi j'ai pas
le choix sinon le monarque est non et je
peux vous dire à tous les cas il mâchait
la baguette et nicolas garreau dernière
question est-ce que vous travaillez le
travail est forcément toute l'année
n'est pas que la saint valentin cette
reprise
j'ai fondé mon argent fin en 2006 fait
depuis leur valise à peu près à mi les
déclarations d'amour effet mal donc
j'organise 3,4
déclaration d'amour spectaculaire par
semaine et c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui
j'ai une date particulière et j'ai une
dizaine de demandes en mariage 1 ces
boues merci pour cette note romantique
merci bien qu à vous merci alors déclaré
comment quel beau métier j'ai trouvé oui
quel beau métier il apporte du bonheur
c'est super déclarer sa flamme le jour
de la saint-valentin quoi de plus
naturel et bien laurence earl propose de
le faire samedi ça se fait vriller à la
maison de la poésie à guyancourt et est
actuellement en répétition et notre
journaliste julie rocha soirée ska
rencontrer elle s'est même prêtée au jeu
vous allez voir un vrai travail
d'investigation journalistique on
regarde si vous n'avez pas d'idées
cadeaux pour cette saint valentin je
vous propose de déclarer simplement
votre flamme c'est facile enfin presque
ne son numéro un avec l'élan courtois
laurence earl à l'origine de l'atelier
spectacle iloveyou qu'il joue ce samedi
à la maison de la poésie les guyancourt
il se peut que la leçon foire
complètement quand je répète déjà j'ai
des surprises qu'on espère que les
personnels ont des réponses qui sont pas
celles que j'attends et tant mieux sur
la base de textes personnels poèmes et
citations sur l'amour le public est
amené à interagir avec l'homme de
théâtre dans un cadre intimiste non
préparés mais dévoué j'ai participé à sa
répétition aujourd'hui histoire que vous
sachiez à quoi vous attendre c'est
l'heure où je suis seul c'est l'heure du
jardin qu'on arrose et descente a
mouillé qui monte des gazons c'est la
honte on désire j'étais nous voir mac ou
de l'arrogance
de niche pas en pros dossier reste
marque
pour les plus timides et ce que la plume
chatouille passons à la leçon numéro 2
comment compter fleurette grâce à
internet la page facebook spotted
repérer a lu vs qu permettent aux
étudiants de l'université versailles
saint quentin en yvelines de s'adresser
des messages anonymes on peut y lire des
hauts- de- enflammé à ma jolie rousse de
l3 aes rh à un grand brun en l1
d'histoire ou encore à ce beau châtain
aux yeux bleus en l3 de sages femmes ils
se reconnaîtront peut-être plus
surprenantes ces déclarations aux
distributeurs et aux toilettes du
premier étage bâtiment vauban la page
créée il ya un mois compte plus de 2300
fans et aurait fait un couple
officiellement déclaré allez maintenant
c'est à vous de jouer
est toujours en plateau avec elisabeth
de feydeau c'est assez drôle cette façon
de communiquer par facebook à l'époque
elle est petite annonce de libération a
déclaré sa flamme comme ça dans
libération maintenant on fait ça de
manière extrêmement moderne et en corse
avant on envoyait qui billets oui quoi
et on va revenir alors isabelle de
feydeau on peut dire que c'est votre vie
est faite de senteurs vous êtes vraiment
l'aspect spécialiste des parfums des
senteurs votre dernier livre s'intitule
l'herbier de marie antoinette qui est
paru chez flammarion racontez nous un
peu ce mot à partir de gravures d'époque
vous faites ressentir ce qu on pouvait
sentir l'époque
j'essaye dans l'herbier en fait l'idée
était plutôt de raconter l'histoire
d'une promenade à partir d'un herbier
imaginaire puisque marc antonette nana
pas en tout cas notre connaissance créé
derbier donc à partir de toutes les
plantes qui hésitaient à petit trianon
petit trianon à l'époque de menthe
honnête j'ai voulu faire une promenade
qui soit une promenade sensorielle donc
finalement comme le jardin au 18e ces
jardins de l'homme sensible c'est à dire
qu'on va se prolonger dans son jardin on
trouve également du réconfort au travers
de la nature et bien
cet herbier composé par des promenades
donc les plantes sont rassemblés selon
les lieux où elles se trouvent ou plus
exactement où elle se trouvait ce que
certaines n'y sont plus et puis moi j'en
profite pour raconter des histoires
d'odeurs et de parfums et puis aussi de
beauté puisque toutes ces plantes et est
souvent utilisé également grâce à des
histoires de parfum sur des plans qui
n'existe plus basse qu'en fait à
l'époque quand même moi j'ai des idées
j'ai les petites astuces quand même gvg
des archives qui me raconte justement
l'utilisation de ces plantes on les
retrouve dans la palette du parfumeur
donc à partir de l'âge pour remonte le
fil
vous est surtout connu pour aller il
s'appelle parfum en fait vous raconter
vraiment l'histoire du parfum
quasiment du moyen âge c'est le leash
paru chez laffont collection bouquins
oui tout à fait c'est histoire
dictionnaire anthologie donc il ya une
partie c'est sûr l'épopée j'appelais
l'épopée parce que pour moi une histoire
du parfum c'est un souffle qui
accompagnent l'histoire des hommes
depuis l'origine jusqu'à nos jours donc
partant du des sentiments les plus des
émotions les plus proches de nous comme
celle de l'intimité l'intériorité
jusqu'aux plus lointaine de notre être
comme celle de la modernité je raconte
l'histoire du parfum qu'est ce qui vous
a donné envie vous de vous intéresser au
parfum je pense qu'en fait vous savez il
ya des choses des phénomènes comme ça
qui nous habite depuis toujours et puis
on en prend tout d'un coup un jour
conscience et moi j'ai vécu dans une
famille où on se plaignait soin de son
odorat parce que visiblement l'aude aura
été assez développée chez ma mère c'est
ma grand mère j'ai toujours eu ma grand
mère qui a été levée en tunisie qui
cuisinait beaucoup qui ne goûtait pas
s'est plaint mekki les sentait elle
travaillait beaucoup dé la pâtisserie
elle l'associé beaucoup avec de saveur
voilà comme la fleur d'oranger
l'utiliser aussi les épices donc tout ça
tu avoues dead je la voyais toujours la
veine à remarquer la pessah tunisie où
elles quand elles ouvraient on y
trouvait des dates des olives mais aussi
des petites concrète de jasmin donc
avait voilà toutes ces odeurs qui me
berçais depuis l'enfance mais on sent en
prendre conscience et puis on parle de
ceux ci j'ai fait de la musique beaucoup
de piano et j'aurais bien aimé
adolescence quand même très développé
ben oui l'europe voilà de fait et puis
en même temps bâle piano c'était pas non
plus très sérieux pour en faire
véritablement une activité j'étais
certainement pas assez doux et non plus
pour ça et du coup je me suis engagé
auprès des classes préparatoires à la
bruyère à versailles donc vers
l'histoire puisque j'aime et où j'aimais
toutes les disciplines j'aime beaucoup
la littérature la philo les longues et
finalement n'arrivant pas à choisir un
de mes professeurs m'avait dit bah prend
l'histoire parce que finalement
l'histoire tu vas se couvrent pas de
couvrir tous voila et tu va utiliser
toutes ces disciplines pour comprendre
l'histoire des hommes et je crois que
c'est ça qui m'intéresse le plus c'est
de comprendre finalement l'histoire de
l'être humain donc voila et puis peu à
peu le parfum est revenu très fortement
tout d'abord avec une rencontre
olfactives à 16 ans ma mère m'avait
emmené pour choisir mon parfum de grande
bonne parfumerie de versailles et puis
là la parfumeuse me proposait des choses
pour mon âge on type câline de pecs
toulouse cristal de chanel est bon il
n'y avait rien qui me m'interpellait
particulièrement et puis j'avais choisi
votre premier parfum saison oui oui oui
enfin maman m'avait dit qu'il fallait
que voilà que c'est l âge de porter un
parfum un petit peu pour se constituer
sa trace et c'est comme un rituel de
féminité le parfum finalement au nom
d'une part ça c'est la preuve d'une
grande maturité pasqua saison il faut
pouvoir avoir les sent suffisamment
développé pour enfin son coût
s'accrocher un parfum je peux vous dire
qu'aujourd'hui les jeunes filles elles
sont très développés quand même parce
qu'elle utilise tellement parfum dès
l'âge de 11 mois que à 16 ans à l'époque
peut-être oui c'était mai mais quand je
vois aujourd'hui les jeunes filles je me
dis que 16 ans j'étais vraiment déjà une
retardé à vos deux premiers parfums
alors relié à la fin mais complètement
changé parce qu'en fait ce parfum quand
je les ai sentis bon déjà le nom m'a
interpellé
je trouve ça tellement romantique comme
donc j'ai voulu le säntis riches les
senti et là c'était une vague qui
m'emporte j'ai envie de dire on a quand
même des parfums en fonction des âges
l'évolution de la vie maintenant vous
allez le même parfum 15 16 ans moi temps
en temps j'ai un peu pikine et ailleurs
mais si vous voulez c'est vrai que je
reste fidèle parce que je l'appelle
toujours ma pantoufle de vair cdr qu'à
la fois c'est confortable et en même
temps j'ai l'impression que ça vous
transforme ça vous donne ses salles
parfum aussi c'est une parure invisible
qui vous conforte qui vous donne une
forme de confiance en soi une envie de
séduire aussi d'importants donc le jour
de la saint-valentin d'avoir le bon
parfum paraît tout à fait il s'appelle
faisant remarquer une courte pause nous
sommes allés dans les de 50 ha pour
demander aux habitants quels étaient
leurs senteurs préférées
puisque ea sports moi c'est tout ce
qu'un peu plus genre muscles - cd parfum
léger c'est plutôt du muguet à des
choses comme ça le côté un peu fleuri et
poivrez plutôt quelque chose de subtil
voilà je n'aime pas ce qui est ce qui
est trop fort voilà est-ce qui peut
accommoder les autres d'ailleurs il
sucre et agréable un peu poivrez un peu
frites est plus subtil que fort ouais
ouais c'est plus agréable quand même un
loader ça fait moins moins agressif on
va dire la rose j'aime bien et puis je
sais pas d'autre est la vanille aussi
c'est très bien j'aime bien tout ce qui
est fraîcheur elle qui fait un peu
sportif j'aime bien tout ça
c'est que les hommes aiment bien le
poivre rien forcément il aime les odeurs
un peu un peu forte oui oui je sais mais
je trouve qu'ils ont enfin me répond t
il pas utiliser un vocabulaire c'est
très approprié si vous êtes bien bien
répondu quels conseils justement on
pourrait donner pour bien choisir un
parfum on sait quelque chose de très
personnel où malgré tout je pense que
c'est difficile d'offrir un parfum à
quelqu'un quand on ne connaît pas bien
et même pour soi je pense qu'il faut
déjà avoir une bonne connaissance de soi
pour choisir le parfum qui vous convient
le mieux on dit d'ailleurs que plus on
se connaît mieux on se parfume donc on
va être de plus en plus vers vraiment ce
qui nous attend le pire c'est des fois
on peut aimer un parfum le problème
c'est que la peau ne peut ne pas
l'apprécier c'est une parfois n'a pas la
même rage à dire odeur ou senteurs en
fonction de la peau s'est alors moi j'ai
déjà impitoyable avec les ravisseurs
prenaient pas et puis on peut aimer un
parfum et puis on va le porter savez
parfum c'est une boîte sont des
molécules donc ces molécules elle vide
sur votre peau et puis notre sens de
l'odorat qui est relié à la partie la
plus archaïque de notre cerveau c'est ce
qu'on appelle la partie limbique va
envoyer des signaux qui nous ramène dans
nos souvenirs donc à la fois nos sens de
souvenirs et nous sensation physique
agréable ou désagréable c'est beau c'est
par exemple on peut aimer un parfum
comme ça on va le porter et puis
finalement sur la peau il va vivre et va
révéler d'autres senteurs d'autres notes
comme on dit et ses notes là vont entrer
en relation avec justement toute cette
partie limbique et nous créer le goût le
dégoût et est fait pour aller eux pour
aller acheter un parfum commun avec la
personne alors faut miel avec la
personne qui mange donne toujours un
conseil qui pas très commercial c'est
quand vais je leur dis prenez des
échantillons parce que surtout n'achetez
pas un parfum sur un coup de tête c'est
à dire que quand vous l'essayez en
parfumerie vous n'êtes que sur les notes
de tête qui vont durer à peu près une
demi heure mais ensuite vous avez bien
d'autres accords qui se révèle et
peut-être que justement cours de la
journée et à certains de ces accords que
vous n'aimerez pas du tout aux qui rompt
avec votre votre système
neurologique pratiquement des
interactions parfaitement négative donc
c'est pour ça qu'il faut prendre son
temps pour choisir un parfum et puis à
des cv mozart disait toujours qu'il faut
rechercher les notes qu'ils s'aiment et
en parfumerie c'est un peu la même chose
vous parliez de la peau tout à l'heure
eh bien il ya des pots qui vont très
très bien faire vivre un parfum et
d'autres peaux pas du tout violent qu'il
faut voilà un drôle même le parent qui
vont les teintes exactement donc c'est
pour ça essayez le parfum prenez des
échantillons vivait avec et si vraiment
vous êtes bien vous vous sentez bien à
ce moment-là adopté ce parfum j'ai même
l'impression de dire si j'ai raison ou
tort que les parfums accroche moins bien
la peau non
ou alors c'est ma peau qui a changé je
parle d'expérience personnelle c'est
pour ça alors c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui
les composants qu'on leur corps au tir
on rajoute oui et des composants qu'on
ne peut plus utiliser notamment tout
sept composants justement qui sont très
liés à la peau mais il n'ya pas que ça
il ya aussi le fait que quand vous
ciblez l'odorat à l'origine primes prime
anne primitivement c'était le sens du
danger chez l'être humain comme chez
tous les mammifères donc on
sentait quand on dit et je sens pas
aujourd'hui on dit toujours c'était que
en fait l'homme avait la lettre du
danger par une odeur qui était inconnu
ce qui est aussi le fait c'est tout ce
qui est nouveau elle fait activement va
déclencher davantage de peur que de
confiance et donc une fois que vous avez
un parfum votre cerveau l'a parfaitement
adaptés l'a parfaitement adapté le fait
que c'était votre parfum donc vous vous
avez l'impression de pulls sentir mais
les autres continuent de sentir donc
c'est ça faut faire attention à ça parce
que tel fois les personnes sur parfume
vous aurez moi je sens plus mais non oui
le voisinage de sommeil après ça peut
incommoder et a préconisé
le terrain ce n'est pas très grave de
côté dernière question sur l'odorat est
ce que c'était un sens qui se perd avec
les années qui avance oui comme la vue
ou comme le monde et bien justement non
justement non c'était indécent ce qui
reste plus stable pendant toute la vie
la seule chose c'est que nous ne le
développons pas nous ne muscles ont pas
nos narines ce qui fait que du coup
notre sens de l'odorat qui était
extrêmement développé à la naissance
puisque le nourrisson reconnaît sa mère
à l'odeur
l'éducation occidentale fait qu'on ne
nous développe pas du tout notre à doha
même si aujourd'hui un peu plus de
prison comprises de conscience par
rapport à l'odorat et du coup il va
s'atrophier 5 en fait on oublie qu'on a
un nez au milieu du visage on oublie
s'en servir et donc on a l'impression
qu'on perd son odorat alors il ya des
maladies ou on perd son domaine mais
vrai nom mais normalement normal et on
fait ses exercices normalement son
odorat reste stable toute sa vie merci
elizabeth merci à l'eau pour toutes ces
renseignements donc alors pensez donc à
muscler vos narines exactement alors à
bien respirer bien fort et pour être
complet complet sans la question si vous
êtes intéressé au parfum une conférence
sur l'histoire de la parfumerie de
l'antiquité à nos jours se déroulent le
mercredi 20 février à l'osm au take 2
versailles bonne saint valentin vous oui
vous assis et puis un autre sujet pour
continuer ses deux suites on va parler
économie c'est la chronique échos du
jeudi